so at Khan Academy we are striving to
create personalized mastery-based
learning that transforms students
mindsets and within that I think there's
a three things that make our value
proposition unique the first is that our
content is provided free of charge for
teachers and students the second is that
we have custom content that's aligned to
standards in different countries so in
Brazil to the B NCC or in the u.s. to
the Common Core and the third is that we
are a technology that's not just a
substitute for paper and pencil and not
such a dramatic change that'd be
overwhelming and you'd have to rethink
everything in your classroom but right
in the middle to offer an innovative
change that is not too overwhelming for
teachers
for us at Khan Academy mastery learning
is fairly simple it's that the
incentives the decisions in class should
be made based on what students are
proving they understand consistently and
in many cases that happens in tests
maybe not till the end of your test but
we think it should be a full year
process building up to that point really
it's not like a yes or no are you fully
mastery based or are you not at all
mastery based there's a spectrum of ways
you can change over your classroom to be
more mastery based when it comes to
personalization though there's a few
things that are really important the
first is that there's the right content
for students and that might not be the
same for all students in the class and
we can help personalize that content but
at the end of the day it is the teacher
that's going to be most effective at
personalizing the content using Khan
Academy and second it's self-paced so
that if I need more practice on a given
topic I can have it I can have like what
we sometimes call a functionally
infinite amount of practice you're not
getting it try again no problem well
when we think about the student mindset
that we'd all hope to have both for
ourselves and for our students I think
it's a student that believes strongly in
their own potential and has the learning
strategies to actually understand
difficult material and so there's a few
ways we try to enable that mindset for
learners on our platform the first is to
remove all barriers to learning so
there's the content accessible for all
students at all times and then there's
support while you're practicing if you
get stuck and so there's no excuse to
not start learning and to not persist
when when you're stuck the focus is on
you the second though is processes to
get unstuck for lack of a better word
right and so you're in the middle of
learning and you're stuck which is
totally fine it's normal it happens to
everyone but right below the practice
it's gonna say are you stuck get help
there's multiple ways that you might
need help you maybe need a hint you
maybe need to watch a video you might
need to ask your teacher but by going
through that process you figure out when
the right time is too
each of those strategies and then the
third is through encouragement that we
give on the site whether you're getting
problems right or wrong that reinforces
the message that it's the effort that
counts
student agency is a really popular topic
right now in education and I think that
sometimes there's a mistake that it's
going from no agency to total agency but
we really see it as a spectrum and on
Khan Academy at a minimum the agency
that we think is important for students
to have would be to answer some
questions like am I on track to complete
these assignments what order am I gonna
work on them and when do I know if I
need help
but as you start to show more maturity
being able to take control a little bit
more of the learning process then you
can start to make some bigger decisions
like what's my actual goal for this week
or this month or the whole school year
what matters to me and when I'm done
with this content are there other
subjects that I want to explore on my
own that aren't even required so the
learning experience on Khan Academy well
it could be different from student to
student I like to think of one students
experience in particular so his name is
Damian he's an 11 year old in Southern
California Los Angeles but I think his
experience could be typical of students
in Sao Paulo or anywhere around the
world there were a few things about his
experience that I think were really
important and that I took away from the
ideal experience on Khan Academy so the
first is that he had a really clear goal
for the year that his teacher had
provided for him on Khan Academy and
every time he logged in the first thing
he saw was his progress toward that big
goal but combined with that big goal
each day as he was practicing he had
really detailed support both
instructional support through the videos
and articles and then the practice
support through the exercises and
challenges and unit tests and not only
that but he also had his teacher there
as a resource if the instructional
resources weren't enough right and there
was this combination of his teacher miss
Chu being an expert about how to use
Khan Academy but also Damien having some
freedom and choice and agency to move on
if he was done to have his own freedom
to choose what he was going to work on
that day so that balance between the
teach
really being able to guide Damien
towards the right material by him also
having freedom and control over his
learning process so you've got the big
goal and the detailed support and you've
got the teacher as the expert but the
students still having the freedom and
that's I think what makes the learning
experience distinct on Khan Academy